- I could go on for hours
about things to think
about with passwords.
Maybe the top two is that initially
that a password needs to be
unique on every different site.
And the reason for that is
that if you share a password,
if you use the same, you
know, your kid's middle name
as the password on three different sites
and any one of those gets broken into,
now the attackers know your
password to use elsewhere.
And unfortunately for
many of us, you know,
there are these rules.
You need to use capital
letters and symbols
and punctuation and numbers
and it becomes impossible to remember,
so what many people do is they come up
with one strong password
and then use it everywhere.
And that's really a
bad idea because again,
you're vulnerable if it gets reused,
if any of those sites gets compromised
now it's out there in the open.
So instead what we recommend
is to use a password manager
which is an app that remembers
and then auto fills wherever you go.
We have the Google password manager,
it's built into Android,
it's built into Chrome.
But other OS makers, other, you know,
vendors have their products.
There's third party ones
that are both free and paid.
Again, you know, you might
get what you pay for,
so don't just take anything out there
but if it's coming from Google,
if it's coming from one
of these big companies,
that's much much better than memorizing
and reusing that same
password in multiple places.
- And that makes a ton of sense.
I mean, when we talk about the passwords
for different websites,
but what about, you know
getting into your device or you know,
your smartwatch or whatever, you know,
and now you have other options, you can,
there's biometrics, your
thumbprint, or your face scan
and all of that.
Does it matter or is it, hey,
this is pretty low risk
that, you know, some spy
from another country is going
to get access to my phone
so I should just, you know,
it's just really to keep my kids out.
- Yeah, so I mean, it depends.
For most of us, what we're dealing with
on device screen locks is
that I left it in a taxi
or a roommate or family
member picked this up.
And so then the threat
model is pretty constrained.
And it generally is
okay to reuse, you know,
to use a simple pin or a biometric.
Now you do have to think about
who else has access to it.
In my own household, I
have very smart kids,
they watch Khan Academy
videos, they've learned a lot.
And so if I set the
same thing for my watch,
my wife's watch, my tablet, my phone,
and they shoulder surf any of those,
we have that same problem of you know,
once it falls in one
place it goes everywhere.
For the most part though, I'm
not that worried about that.
- I have to say my
oldest son, if there was
like an Olympics for this,
he would be a medalist.
He can't help it.
He knows he, but if someone,
if you're in the room
he somehow knows exactly
what you typed in.
So anyway, yes, beware.
And I think he's a force for
good, but there might be -
- Yeah, I mean, foreign
spies and 10 year old kids
like there's a, you know,
interesting Venn diagram there.